你说老公虽然说我是个独生女，
如果我现在不把实实在在的利益搞到咱们孩子名下的话，
假设我爸再给我生个妹妹，
再给我生个弟弟，
那到时候这些东西可就不归我们家孩子了，
所以我觉得姓什么东西不重要，
再说了，
我们可以再生一个孩子，
我再跟你姓都不重要。
我现在27岁，
我是独生女，
去年刚生了一个男宝，
目前是我自己年带，
因为我是独生女，
然后我爸一直想要一个男宝，
她就很希望我在生下一个跟我姓的孩子，
但是因为我在怀的时候，
我是去测过了的，
我肚子里面怀的是男孩子，
但是她一直也没有跟我说，
毕竟我老公也不是入赘嘛，
然后我就说大的呢，
先跟我老公家姓，
生了第二个呢，
然后再跟我爸姓，
我生下来男孩以后，
我爸就有点反悔的意思，
很想要我现在这个大儿子能跟我姓，
他就是那种传统观念，
就很想传宗接代的那一种。
我每次回来我们都能吵架，
就是包括很开心的一件事情也能吵，
让我过3年，
让我去做个试管，
生一对龙凤胎，
也是想要有个孩子能跟我家姓。
我之前有一段恋爱就是因为这个性的问题分手了，
困扰了我很多年，
因为我是独生女，
家里呀，
包括整个家族给我的压力很大。
二的那一种，
因为我不知道要怎么办，
但是说实话，
从我自己来说的话，
我并不是想要二胎，
但是因为我就是家里给我的这种压力，
就好像我不得不生二胎的那种感觉，
你自己是做什么工作呀？
我是做工程的，
但是目前的话我是自己一个人在家里带孩子，
你做工程这个工作需要靠你爸爸吗？
不需要，
都是我自己的，
你老公是做什么工作的呢？
我老公是在一家国企，
比较的稳定，
你说大钱的话是没有的，
但是生活就是比较的安逸，
老公的父母是干啥的呢？
我老公的父母是在老家开超市的，
做生意，
家庭条件也还可以，
但是对比我爸的家庭条件来说的话，
可能会差一点，
因为我爸的就是他是自己开工厂的，
做的还可以，
周围的老板都是挺有钱的那一种，
所以他就是很想要一个男孩子能跟到他姓的那种感觉，
你老公是独子吗？
我老公不是，
我老公是哥哥，
他还有个弟弟，
如果在这种情况下假设啊，
我说假设你爸肯花100万给你们两口子买房，
或者肯花100万给你们两口子买什么东西，
你老公有没有可能啊，
就说孩子跟老爷姓，
这个孩子如果是能跟我姓的话，
我爸会直接给他买房，
直接会给他铺面，
因为现在这个孩子已经上了户口，
已经。
信了，
我老公家的信了，
那你突然在改，
就感觉很那个啥，
这事儿啊，
价钱到了都好商量，
明白吗？
我是这种态度，
如果我是男的啊，
真的孩子跟谁信这个事儿，
本来我也不是独子，
我家里还有哥哥，
我家里还有弟弟，
哎呀，
价钱到了都好商量，
如果说你爸愿意出几百万，
或者说愿意出房子，
愿意出店铺的话，
可以，
我觉得这事儿的话就跟你老公说，
你说老公虽然说我是个独生女，
如果我现在不把实实在在的利益搞到咱们孩子名下的话，
假设我爸再给我生个妹妹，
再给我生个弟弟，
那到时候这些东西可就不归我们家孩子了，
所以我觉得姓什么东西不重要，
再说了，
我们可以再生一个孩子，
再跟你姓都不重要，
我要是你的话，
我可能就会这么跟我老公说，
再说了，
老公你看啊，
你家里面又有哥哥又有弟弟的啊，
咱还是实实在在的利益，
你说我爸要是给我一个房子200万的话，
咱俩得攒多久钱才能攒够这200万呀，
这孩子名下要有一套200万的房产的话，
我觉得实实在在的利益比较靠谱，
我他是你的话，
我就跟老公这么说，
我说如果我要是不答应他，
你说我爸要是再给我搞个私生子出来，
那我们以后我家孩子还能摊上啥呀？
咱俩孩子还能摊上啥呀？
就这么聊，
我老公也是同意的，
主要是他家里吧来说同意那就。
既然你老公同意，
我就是发自肺腑的真诚的这事儿就是感谢你老公这么通情达理，
感谢你老公思想这么开，
你感谢你老公没有受到封建思想的残害，
你就从这一点说了，
老公我觉得你真的是思想可先进了，
就比那种受封建残余比我爸强多了，
你就这么聊呗，
这不就皆大欢喜吗？
你老公又不是特别在意这个事儿，
然后我们又通过这个事情给孩子争取到了实实在在的利益，
然后你爸这头又高兴了，
又满意了，
这多好，
如果是早说的话，
孩子还没有上来，
现在孩子改名字方便不很，
今天改明天就去过户，
给那个老爷，
赶紧给孩子过户一套门面，
赶紧给孩子过户一套房啊，
那跟我公公婆婆那边先不说，
公公婆婆那边，
你回到老家了，
你会拿户口本回去给他们看吗？
你会拿身份证回给他们看吗？
在公公婆婆那边，
她姓张，
还叫张笑宝，
就是公公婆婆那边过年的时候你还叫张笑宝，
嗯，
跟他说啥干啥，
但是感觉迟早有一天会泄露，
泄露了到时候木已成舟了。
再说啊，
只要你老公不反对，
这事儿就好办啊，
这婆天的富贵得接住啊，
好的，
我查到了，
好抓紧啊，
抓紧先把落袋为安的东西先弄到手里，
是的，
因为我觉得这都是实实在在的钱，
对呀，
你想啊，
这100万。
老公和你吭哧吭哧得攒多少年，
200万，
你们两口子得攒多少年，
一个姓而已啊，
可是我现在我爸又是觉得，
他每次也是很纠结的，
他觉得现在又来改这个孩子，
他也觉得不好，
他就老是想让我再生，
先改，
先给他，
等拿到手了，
先拿到手以后的事儿以后再说，
孩子小很好改的啊，
好改，
只要你们两口子同意，
马上去，
马上改，
我现在愿意改他的姓，
我爸也现在也不一定愿意把那个东西给我，
那咱得嬉笑怒骂，
咱得商量好了，
而且是当着你，
当着你老公的面让你爸答应，
这才具有很强的这个约束力哦。
然后我爸还很容易被人骗，
就是他很相信别人，
然后我们家里人说有的东西他都不信，
动不动就是投资100万啊，
动不动就是50万，
这样子丢出去，
与其让别人劝他不如我嘞，
就是说哪里有个投资啊，
我跟我妈就是自己人劝他都劝不住的，
他就很相信别人，
你赶紧的吧，
你再这么犹犹豫豫下去的话，
我的天呐，
我都心疼那个钱啊，
赶紧的啊，
那如果对于我妈来说的话，
像这种情况的话，
他要怎么维护自己的利益，
或者是他去做个财产公证会比较好呢？
因为我爸真的是这个钱在手里，
真的就是容易被骗出去，
你妈要是真那个什么的话，
他可以打官司，
我不一样，
我就想分财产，
为什么呢？
因为我老公他有可能这个恶意转移财产啊，
或者有可能藏匿财产啊，
或有可能被。
骗呀呀，
他已经被骗了多少钱了呀，
有可能造成我的损失呀，
我可以打官司分财产，
哪些财产先分到我名下是我的，
但这事儿我感觉不要轻易搞啊，
先还是和和气气的把你和孩子的利益先拿到手再说，
行，
好，
我知道了，
就这样啊，
谢谢，
可以起来，
我感觉有很多东西，
就思路一个打开，
金钱自然来，
记得点赞关注哦。